Yabuki makes her Street Fighter 5 debut
at the end of June and she's bringing a
big bag of tricks with her we recently
had some hands-on time with the teenage
kunoichi and this is what we thought
right Ibuki feels like a versatile
character that is capable of putting our
big damage in bursts however she doesn't
have a lot of health and really making
the most of her can be quite tricky this
is because her special moves require
resource management and good selves take
a kunai for example unlike in previous
games the booty needs to be very
judicious with them since you can only
carry six at a time once they're gone
they need to be replenished how many
she's able to fish out of her pocket
depends on how long you hold the button
down in a Tatsu motion since the full
restock has a longer animation she's
open to attack which means restocks will
have to be carefully timed three fighter
four players will be also glad to hear
that the dreaded kunai vortex is gone
for now Yabuki screw knives can be used
in various ways on the ground she
launches them diagonally down in front
of her with light punch kunai traveling
the shortest and hot punch going the
farthest corners can also be used to
make any cancelable normal attacks safe
on block since it has a good amount push
back holding a punch button down and
then releasing while on the ground will
throw kunais laterally across the screen
and holding kick buns and then releasing
in the air will chuck a cluster of
kunai's downwards finally the e X
version of kunai's explode on contact
which can be used to deal extra damage
or launch the opponent into a job of
fake
like most projectiles kunai's are very
effective at controlling space but the
fact that Ibuki has them on the ground
and in the air means you'll really have
to respect a projectile game it's worth
knowing that an opponent's projectile or
a well-timed light attack can knock
standard kunai's out of the air when
evictees be triggers activate she throws
out a bomb depending on whether you're
holding back forward or nothing is
explode at different times the V trigger
bar will then start depleting and she
has a limited window to throw a second
bomb these comically large bombs are
incredibly disruptive and it's difficult
to tell exactly when they'll explode
which makes them great for relieving
pressure naturally they also help
themselves for example if you keys c'mon
- can be used to quickly travel across
the screen and through an opponent on to
the other side this puts him in a spot
where they have to deal with an
explosion and possibly an overhead or a
grab
of course bombs can also be used to
extend combos for example and one of her
many target combos by activating V
trigger to throw the bomb out then use a
light punch and cancel into a excu nice
push them into the bomb which will then
send them flying into the air where
every key can follow up with even more
attacks ourselves bombs can also be
triggered early by throwing an explosive
kunai at them
and the positioning can be moved around
by a tack room directly with punches or
kicks v-trigger bombs will no doubt
become a core part of maximizing Ibuki
damage Airport is also a fantastic way
of dissuading players from rushing
relieving pressure and generally
upsetting the flow of the match other
tools in a bookies arsenal include herby
skill which functions much like Karin's
palm strike and cancels out projectiles
it can also be charged so that when it's
blocked it remains relatively safe she
can also come and grab during which he
summons an energy ball much like
Naruto's Rasengan and plunges it into
her opponent launching them across the
screen this is handy to back the
opponent to a corner or knock them down
for more setups in terms of mobility the
booty has quite a fast walk speed but
you can also leap into the air and use a
parachute to glide for a short distance
this is great for escaping corners or
needs to be well timed since players can
chase her down and capture
on her vulnerability while she's falling
Ibuki can cover for this somewhat by
throwing a single kunai largely she has
a shot you can like kicks but unlike the
show you cans there's no invincibility
on these if it hits the e X version can
be canceled at the very top of its arc
into a kunai or an exp knife or a juggle
overall Ibuki feels like she's going to
emerge as one of the stronger characters
in the three-point-five roster and many
specials and target combos are great for
controlling space and dishing out big
damage the sheer number of abilities she
has makes her great for overwhelming at
home but to balance this out she has
very low health she feels very much like
a glass cannon for morals free fire 5
including videos on the game's upcoming
story mode keep an eye on GameSpot's
youtube page and don't forget to
subscribe
devour
you